Imagínate un escenario súper común, digamos, en cualquier guardia médica a
las 3 de la mañana.
Uf, la hora donde todos los errores ocurren.
Totalmente. Y bueno, llegan los resultados del laboratorio de un paciente.
En la pantalla tienes tres indicadores distintos, todos parpadeando en rojo,
y todos gritando con absoluta seguridad que el paciente tiene un exudado
pleural.
Claro, y la inercia te dice que actúes ya.
Exacto. Así que, lógicamente, el equipo médico cambia todo el plan de tratamiento.
Empiezan a buscar cáncer o tuberculosis.
Pero a ver, ¿qué pasa si resulta que la pastilla diaria que el paciente toma
para el corazón acaba de engañar a esos tres marcadores al mismo tiempo?
Sí, esa es una trampa clínica de manual.
Y lo peor, de verdad, lo peor es que está disfrazada de datos objetivos, o
sea, de números que parecen irrefutables.
Sí, nos acostumbramos a pensar que la medicina interna es como, no sé, como la
ingeniería.
Tal cual. Mides algo, aplicas una fórmula matemática y listo.
Y ahí es exactamente donde el panorama
se vuelve turbio. Por eso, bienvenidos a esta inmersión clínica a fondo.
La misión de hoy es diseccionar un caso socrático de medsemiotics,
específicamente sobre el derrame pleural exudativo.
Y utilizando evidencia pura, sacada directamente de medsemiotics-db.
Exactamente. Pero ojo, el objetivo no es recitar la fisiología básica que
cualquiera puede leer en un libro de texto.
La meta de este análisis es ver cómo la probabilidad real de una enfermedad
cambia con cada nuevo hallazgo.
Y sobre todo, desarmar esas trampas cognitivas donde incluso los clínicos más
experimentados resbalan, ¿eh?
A las 3 de la mañana.
Sí, totalmente. A ver, vamos a desempacar esto paso a paso.
Empecemos con el caso clínico base.
Venga, ponnos en situación.
Bueno, se trata de un varón de 68 años.
Es ex fumador, tiene antecedentes de insuficiencia cardíaca con fracción de
eyección reducida y su tratamiento incluye furosemida de forma diaria.
Bien, un paciente complejo, pero muy típico.
Sí, bastante típico. El motivo de consulta es que lleva cinco semanas con disnea
de esfuerzo progresiva.
O sea, un deterioro funcional que ya es evidente.
Así es, pero hay que sumar piezas a este rompecabezas.
El paciente presenta tos seca, un dolor sordo en el costado derecho
y una pérdida de peso de unos 4 kilos que no ha buscado.
Wow.
Sí, 4 kilos, sin picos febriles y bueno, el paciente
refiere que siente que el diurético ya no le hace efecto.
Pero si revisamos el historial reciente, ojo aquí, no hay aumento
de peso.
Ah, qué interesante.
Tampoco hay edemas nuevos en los miembros inferiores.
Y sigue durmiendo con la misma cantidad de almohadas de siempre.
O sea, no hay ortopnea nueva.
Exacto. Y las constantes vitales son completamente normales.
Sin fiebre, frecuencia cardíaca en 92, respiratoria en 22,
normotenso, y está saturando al 93% con aire ambiente.
Pero algo tiene que haber en la placa.
Pues sí, la radiografía de tórax revela un derrame derecho.
Ocupa menos de la mitad del hemitórax.
Y no hay absolutamente nada de líquido en el lado izquierdo.
Bueno, con este panorama sobre la mesa, la inercia clínica, como decíamos antes,
podría empujar a una decisión muy rápida.
Y por eso les lanzo esta pregunta para pensar.
Quienes nos escuchan, tómense unos tres segundos reales para analizarlo.
El paciente tiene insuficiencia cardíaca y un derrame pleural.
¿Por qué no basta con simplemente aumentar la dosis de furosemida
y citarlo en dos semanas para revisión?
Uno, dos, tres.
Bueno, la respuesta es porque el cuadro clínico no se comporta como una verdadera
descompensación cardíaca.
Claro.
Es verdad que, por pura estadística, cuando un paciente con insuficiencia
cardíaca hace un derrame unilateral, pues suele ser en el lado derecho.
De hecho, la lateralidad no es el problema aquí.
Sí, el problema es que el resto del sistema no muestra signos de congestión.
Exactamente.
No hay ortopnea nueva, el peso no sube por retención de
líquidos, no hay edemas.
A ver, pero un corazón fallando sí puede causar disnea, ¿no?
Desde luego que sí.
Pero no podemos ignorar las banderas rojas.
Tenemos un ex fumador de 68 años con una pérdida de peso
inexplicada.
Y el dolor torácico sordo.
Sí, ese dolor nos habla de inflamación, de una afectación directa de la
pleura. Y eso es algo que un simple trasudado por fallo cardíaco rara vez
produce. La lección vital aquí es que tener una enfermedad crónica de
base no confiere una inmunidad mágica contra patologías nuevas.
O sea, tener una causa clarísima para un trasudado no te protege contra el
desarrollo de un exudado.
Tal cual. Y esto plantea una pregunta importante.
La pregunta no es si el paciente tiene o no un derrame.
A ver, la placa de tórax ya resolvió eso.
Sí, el líquido está ahí.
La verdadera pregunta diagnóstica es, ¿este derrame es un exudado?
Es decir, ¿estamos frente a una pleura enferma, digamos, atacada por un tumor
o por una infección?
¿O es simplemente el líquido filtrado por una presión hidrostática alta?
Exacto. Y para responder a eso, la clínica nos ha llevado a un punto
ciego. La única manera real de desempatar esto es ir directamente a la
fuente.
¿Pinchar?
Sí. Extraer el líquido y mirarlo bajo el microscopio.
Pues pasemos entonces a la exploración física.
En la base del hemitórax derecho, el médico encuentra matidez a la percusión,
disminución de las vibraciones vocales y abolición del murmullo
vesicular.
Y a ver, antes de seguir tirando números, detengámonos en la física de esto.
Me parece perfecto. No es solo recitar signos de memoria.
Exacto. ¿Por qué ocurre esta triada exacta?
Yo lo veo como un tema de transmisión acústica pura.
Normalmente el pulmón lleno de aire no es el mejor conductor del sonido del mundo,
pero permite que escuchemos el aire entrando y saliendo.
Claro, el sonido de las cuerdas vocales baja y genera esa resonancia que palpamos
en la pared torácica.
Sí, pero cuando se interpone un litro de líquido entre el pulmón y la pared, ese
líquido actúa como un aislante acústico masivo.
Total. Las vibraciones vocales rebotan, el murmullo del aire se
silencia por completo, y al percutir, pues, suena a madera sólida, a
matidez pura.
En lugar del hueco de un tambor, que es lo normal.
Bien, con esa sospecha clínica en mente, se realiza una ecografía a pie de cama.
Se observa un espacio anecoico, completamente negro en la pantalla, entre la
pared torácica y el pulmón, flotando por encima del diafragma.
Y asumo que no hay tabiques, ¿verdad?
No, no hay tabiques.
Se procede entonces a una toracocentesis diagnóstica, extrayendo un líquido
amarillo turbio.
Y un detalle fundamental aquí, se extrae sangre del paciente en ese mismísimo
momento.
Ah, un paso que jamás, pero jamás debe olvidarse.
Los gradientes necesitan muestras simultáneas para ser precisos.
Totalmente.
Pero aquí es donde me topo con algo en la evidencia de medsemiotics-db que me
chocó bastante.
A ver, cuéntame.
En el documento, bajo el hallazgo específico de derrame pleural, el estado
dice literalmente LR no medible.
Ah, sí.
Y a ver, sabiendo que la ecografía es el estándar de oro actual en la cabecera del
paciente,
¿cómo es posible que no se asigne un cociente de verosimilitud a un hallazgo
ecográfico tan claro?
Es una excelente duda, y la verdad toca el núcleo mismo de cómo interpretamos
la probabilidad en la medicina basada en evidencia.
Un LR, o cociente de verosimilitud, es básicamente el
multiplicador de nuestra sospecha inicial.
Claro, nos dice con qué fuerza una prueba empuja el diagnóstico hacia un lado o
hacia otro.
Exacto, pero en la estructura de esta evidencia en particular, el derrame pleural
es la condición de entrada.
O sea, es como el boleto para entrar al estudio clínico.
Así mismo. Todos los pacientes en esta base de datos ya tienen líquido en la
pleura. Sin ese líquido, pues no hay nada que dividir entre exudado o
trasudado.
Entiendo. O sea, la ecografía es espectacular para confirmar que el líquido está
ahí físicamente.
Sí, pero su capacidad para mirar un líquido anecoico todo negro en la pantalla y
decir, esto es cáncer o esto es un fallo cardíaco, es prácticamente nula.
Detecta, pero no clasifica.
Y hay otra razón vital para usar esa sonda ecográfica y ver el diafragma, ¿verdad?
Pensando en la pesadilla de cualquier residente en su primera guardia.
Uf, la pesadilla de confundir un derrame con líquido subdiafragmático.
Terrible.
Si uno asume que una matidez basal es un derrame, así, sin más, e
inserta una aguja sin mirar, puede atravesar el diafragma y ahí terminas
puncionando el hígado.
O un vaso.
O drenando ascitis creyendo que estás en la pleura.
Por eso la ecografía tiene que demostrar sin lugar a dudas que ese espacio negro
está por encima de la línea blanca del diafragma.
Bueno, volvamos al caso. Tenemos el líquido turbio y la sangre fresca.
Y aquí es donde entran en juego los famosos criterios de Light.
Los clásicos.
Los resultados muestran proteínas pleurales en 4.1 gramos por
decilitro y proteínas séricas en 6.8.
El cociente es 0.6.
Supera el límite de 0.5, así que ya tenemos un primer criterio
positivo.
Seguimos. LDH en el líquido pleural de 310 unidades por litro y
en el suero de 220. El laboratorio marca el límite superior normal del suero
en 250.
Bueno, eso nos deja un cociente pleural sérico de 1.4.
Sí. Y además, la LDH pleural de 310
supera ampliamente los dos tercios del límite superior normal del suero.
O sea, se cumplen los tres criterios de Light.
Y recordemos que la base de datos medsemiotics-db también
evalúa umbrales absolutos.
Esa LDH pleural superior a 200 ya es un indicador por sí
misma.
Bien, pregunta analítica para la audiencia.
Tómense tres segundos para pensar.
Sabiendo que los criterios de Light son una prueba concebida para ser altamente
sensible, ¿qué cociente específico registra la base de medsemiotics
DB y qué conclusión permite sacar en este paciente particular?
Bueno,
aquí es donde la base
de datos es brutalmente honesta.
Solo registra el cociente de verosimilitud negativo.
Un LR negativo de 0.04.
Exacto.
Con un intervalo de confianza estrecho entre 0.02 y 0.11.
Y el umbral documentado es la ausencia de los tres criterios.
A ver, en términos prácticos, un LR de 0.04 aplasta la
probabilidad.
Totalmente.
Si no cumples ningún criterio, la posibilidad de que sea un exudado cae por
un precipicio.
Esa es la magia real de los criterios de Light.
Su poder es destructivo. Sirven para descartar.
Si todo da negativo, pues respiras tranquilo.
Es un trasudado.
Pero el documento omite intencionalmente dar un LR positivo.
Exacto. No hay un número mágico para cuando el criterio se cumple.
Yo lo veo con una analogía, para visualizarlo mejor.
Es como usar una red de pesca industrial con una malla finísima.
A ver, me gusta eso.
Sí, atrapa absolutamente todos los peces valiosos del océano, que en nuestro caso
serían los exudados reales.
Claro.
Pero cuando levantas esa red al barco, también viene llena de algas, latas
oxidadas y botas viejas, o sea, los falsos positivos.
Y en el caso de este paciente de 68 años, tenemos la bota vieja más
engañosa de toda la medicina interna.
La famosa trampa del diurético.
Y aquí es donde necesito hacer de abogado del diablo, si me permitas.
Adelante, dispara.
Si la furosemida es un diurético potente que elimina el líquido del cuerpo para
aliviar el corazón,
¿por qué no elimina también las proteínas y la LDH de la pleura de forma
proporcional?
¿No deberían bajar todos los niveles al mismo tiempo?
Suena lógico, pero es una cuestión de permeabilidad y tamaño molecular.
La furosemida actúa en el riñón, bajando el volumen de agua en todo el sistema
vascular.
Bien, hasta ahí estamos de acuerdo.
Entonces, cuando la presión hidrostática baja, el cuerpo intenta reabsorber
líquido del espacio pleural hacia los capilares.
Pero los capilares pleurales son membranas semipermeables.
Ah, claro. El agua es una molécula diminuta.
Exacto. El agua cruza rápidamente de vuelta a la sangre.
Pero la enzima LDH es una macromolécula gigante, y las
proteínas también lo son.
Entonces se quedan atrapadas en la cavidad.
Tal cual. El agua se evapora, figurativamente hablando, y los solutos
pesados se concentran. El resultado es un líquido pleural que, aunque
originado por un simple problema de presión cardíaca, ahora tiene una densidad de
proteínas y LDH tan alta que los criterios de Light lo leen como un
exudado.
O sea, un falso positivo fisiológico.
Un exudado fabricado por el propio tratamiento.
Y el juicio clínico aquí es crucial, porque la base de datos no tiene una
fórmula matemática exacta para corregir esto.
No hay un LR documentado que ajuste el impacto de la furosemida.
¿Y qué nos exige la evidencia entonces?
Ante un paciente con diuréticos y un Light positivo, la evidencia te
exige detenerte.
Tienes que pedir pruebas de confirmación que no dependan tanto de esos gradientes
alterados.
Bueno, y aquí es donde se pone realmente interesante la cosa.
En el líquido de nuestro paciente se solicita colesterol, un marcador clave.
El resultado muestra un colesterol pleural de 78 mg por
decilitro y un sérico de 190.
Esto nos da un cociente de 0.41.
Y con esos números, ya entramos de lleno en el territorio de los marcadores
confirmatorios.
Revisemos los cocientes de verosimilitud documentados en la evidencia para estas
pruebas.
La LDH pleural elevada, por encima de 200, tiene un LR
positivo de 18.
Un número bastante fuerte.
Sí. Luego, el cociente de colesterol pleural sobre sérico, mayor a 0.3,
tiene un LR positivo de 14.
Bien.
Y luego tenemos el colesterol pleural aislado, cuando supera los 55 miligramos
por decilitro,
que muestra un LR positivo reportado como un rango enorme.
De 7.1 a 250.
Sin una estimación puntual fija.
Exacto, sin estimación puntual.
Así que piensen en un escenario frecuente de hospital.
Tres segundos para pensarlo.
Un colega revisa la literatura rápida, ve ese límite superior y te dice,
mira, el colesterol pleural aislado tiene un cociente de verosimilitud de 250.
Este paciente tiene 78.
La probabilidad de exudado acaba de subir al 99.9%.
Caso cerrado.
¿Qué le contestamos a ese colega?
1, 2, 3.
Pues le contestamos que está jugando a los dados con las estadísticas.
Totalmente. Tomar un rango de 7.1 a 250 y elegir
convenientemente el 250 es un sesgo de confirmación de manual.
Y además, la fuente resumen que agrupa la evidencia no especifica la calidad
metodológica ni el tamaño de la muestra de los estudios que arrojaron esos picos
extremos.
Presumir de esa certeza artificial es muy peligroso.
Entonces, ¿qué debería sacar el clínico de ese rango?
La dirección de la flecha.
Incluso si tomamos el límite más pesimista, ese 7.1,
sigue siendo un salto probabilístico sustancial que confirma un exudado.
Claro.
Por eso medsemiotics-db lo posiciona como una herramienta potente,
pero se niega a darle un número fijo que infle nuestra confianza falsamente.
Ahora, llevemos esto a la calculadora bayesiana.
Otro momento para que la audiencia piense tres segunditos.
Si sabemos que la LDH pleural por sí sola tiene un LR positivo
de 18, ¿deberíamos multiplicar ese número por el LR de 14
del colesterol para estar matemáticamente acorazados en nuestro
diagnóstico?
Uno, dos, tres.
Esta es quizás la trampa matemática más común en todo el razonamiento clínico.
Y la respuesta es un no rotundo, ¿verdad?
No se puede multiplicar.
Bajo ninguna circunstancia.
Pero, a ver, explícamelo.
Si ambas pruebas miden el líquido y ambas salieron altísimas, lógicamente me siento
el doble de seguro de que hay un proceso inflamatorio grave.
¿Por qué la matemática me frena ahí?
Porque el teorema de Bayes requiere que las pruebas sean completamente
independientes para poder encadenarlas.
Y aquí, amigo mío, no lo son.
No son independientes.
Para nada. Tanto la acumulación de la enzima LDH como la
acumulación de colesterol derivan de exactamente la misma falla fisiopatológica,
un aumento patológico en la permeabilidad vascular de la pleura o
la destrucción celular in situ.
Y además estamos midiendo ambos marcadores en la misma jeringa de líquido, sacada
en el mismo bendito segundo.
Exacto. El colesterol llega ahí porque las células inflamatorias se degradan
o porque la barrera capilar está tan rota que deja pasar las lipoproteínas.
Al final del día, ambas pruebas están gritando que la puerta de la membrana pleural
se quedó abierta. Multiplicar un LR de 18 por uno de 14 sería
como contar la misma puerta abierta dos veces.
Matemáticamente, inflarías la probabilidad posprueba a un porcentaje ficticio que
rozaría al infinito. La forma rigurosa de actuar aquí es usar el
LR más robusto por sí solo, en este caso el de la LDH
pleural o el cociente de colesterol.
Y observar que el otro marcador coincide y apoya la dirección clínica, pero sin
multiplicar nada.
Esa es la clave.
Llegamos entonces al momento de interpretar el cuadro completo.
El laboratorio nos entrega los análisis restantes de líquido.
Hay predominio de linfocitos.
Los niveles de glucosa son normales.
El pH es un sólido 7.38.
La tinción de Gram no muestra bacterias.
Y el paciente sigue sin registrar temperatura alta.
Bueno.
Con la LDH y el colesterol confirmando el diagnóstico en paralelo,
Y superando con creces los umbrales para descartar la trampa de la furosemida, la
conclusión no deja lugar a dudas.
Estamos ante un exudado genuino.
Definitivamente.
Y si conectamos todo el razonamiento, esta confirmación no es solo un ejercicio
académico bonito.
Esto cambia radicalmente el destino del paciente.
El plan ya no puede ser, vamos a ajustar el diurético y ver qué pasa con su
corazón.
Absolutamente no.
El fallo cardíaco no es el culpable primario de este líquido.
Hay un proceso agresivo ocurriendo en ese pulmón.
Tenemos a un paciente en su sexta década, ex fumador pesado,
que está perdiendo peso de forma insidiosa, con un dolor sordo y un
exudado dominado por linfocitos.
Es un escenario que te obliga a pensar en etiologías graves de inmediato.
Sí, la sospecha de una neoplasia maligna, digamos un carcinoma
broncogénico oculto o metástasis pleurales, salta a la cima de la
lista.
Y dependiendo del contexto epidemiológico local, de donde nos escuchen,
una tuberculosis pleural también encaja perfectamente con un líquido linfocitario
unilateral sin fiebre alta inicial.
Exactamente.
Y la fuente establece directrices muy, pero muy estrictas sobre cómo
proceder a partir de aquí.
Los próximos pasos clínicos son innegociables.
Se requiere enviar el líquido para citología, buscando células malignas, cultivo
específico para micobacterias y medición de adenosina desaminasa.
La famosa ADA.
Sí. Además, el protocolo indica una tomografía de tórax con contraste.
Y ojo, un detalle técnico importante, la tomografía rinde muchísimo más si
se hace después de evacuar gran parte del derrame.
Claro, para que el líquido no comprima el parénquima pulmonar.
Exacto, y esconde pequeños nódulos malignos.
Si todo eso vuelve negativo o inconcluso, el paso final lógico es una
biopsia pleural.
Pero junto con todo este rigor diagnóstico, hay que aplicar un rigor crítico sobre
nuestra propia herramienta de evidencia.
Es cierto.
Parte de usar la medicina basada en la evidencia es ser transparente sobre los
puntos ciegos de las bases de datos.
Claro, lo que medsemiotics-db no sabe o simplemente no puede afirmar con los
datos actuales.
Sí, por un lado, no tenemos una probabilidad pre-prueba universal
documentada para el exudado.
En los macroestudios, que evalúan miles de toracocentesis, no hay un
consenso limpio que diga
el 40% son exudados en la población general que llega a urgencias.
Y tratar de sumar las prevalencias de cáncer, neumonía y tuberculosis para
fabricar esas cifras sería un error metodológico grave.
Terrible. Y por otro lado, está el impacto exacto del diurético, que ya
discutimos.
Sabemos que la furosemida arruina la especificidad de los criterios de Light,
pero la base no ofrece una tasa exacta de reclasificación o un
índice de corrección matemática perfecta.
O sea, nos obliga a operar en ese margen de incertidumbre funcional.
Totalmente. La medicina clínica real exige que entendamos la dirección de la
evidencia, incluso cuando el número exacto no está disponible.
Entonces, para ir cerrando, ¿qué significa todo esto en la práctica?
Si mañana en la guardia tienen que enfrentarse a un paciente que respira con
dificultad por un derrame, la regla de oro que deben recordar es esta.
A ver.
Las pruebas de líquido pleural tienen flechas de dirección única.
No funcionan igual hacia arriba que hacia abajo.
Los criterios de Light son una red gigante diseñada para descartar.
Su poder reside casi enteramente en el resultado negativo.
Por el contrario, la LDH y el colesterol son lupas
confirmatorias. Y si el paciente tiene furosemida u otro diurético en su
historial reciente, un Light positivo no es una sentencia firme de exudado.
Es una alarma de incendios pidiendo que confirmes con los otros marcadores antes de
alterar la vida del paciente.
Y mira, como pensamiento provocador final, para dejar a quienes nos
escuchan, me gustaría retomar esa imposibilidad matemática de multiplicar los
cocientes del colesterol y la LDH.
Lo entendimos bien porque ambos miden la misma filtración en la misma gota de
líquido, ¿verdad? Pero la medicina moderna está inundada de
automatización. Recibimos paneles con 20, 30 resultados simultáneos.
Uf, perfiles completos, donde vemos cinco valores distintos alterados al mismo
tiempo y el cerebro automáticamente dice, ah, estoy segurísimo del diagnóstico.
Ese es el verdadero peligro.
¿Cuántas veces en la práctica diaria estamos experimentando una inmensa y
falsa seguridad clínica simplemente porque la máquina nos imprime cinco indicadores
en rojo, sin detenernos a pensar que a nivel celular,
fisiopatológicamente, esos cinco indicadores están midiendo exactamente el
mismo fenómeno biológico redundante?
Es una ilusión de certeza construida sobre datos repetidos.
Es un recordatorio fantástico de que procesar números nunca,
pero nunca, reemplazará el pensar en la fisiología del paciente.
Y bueno, con esa idea cerramos esta inmersión clínica a fondo.
Me encantó. El rigor analítico debe guiar el proceso, pero es el
entendimiento del mecanismo oculto lo que evita que caigamos en la trampa.
Totalmente de acuerdo. Hasta el próximo análisis de evidencia.